well those so-called covet issues sure
haven't stopped her from visiting
the rest of the country with covet
issues she's traveled coast to coast
all since being tapped to lead the
border response here with reaction
texas gop congressman and former sheriff
troy nails
sheriff good morning to you good morning
steve good morning everyone
uh so she says we have to deal with uh
covet issues
covet is an issue everywhere what what's
she worried about is she worried
uh that she might get it because because
she's been vaccinated
or is she worried that they coming in
have a higher infection rate or what are
these covet issues
that's the excuse that this
administration is going to use
and look at her she's been jet setting
around this country going to all the
different blue states talking about this
this infrastructure plan and everything
else so
no this isn't covered kamala and you
know it
you just don't want to visit the
southern border because you know what
you're going to hear
you're going to hear from the border
patrol department of public safety
immigration small town mayors and
everyone that lives along that southern
border
that you are doing a horrible job you're
in complete denial
and you need to fix the southern border
that's what she would hear if she
visited it
so she's going to use the excuse like
everything else
covey yeah um you know you've got to
wonder
when she says there's a covet issue if
if you're talking about
the danger there would that mean that
our border patrol enforcement people
would be in peril just by simply being
down there
if there's a covet issue well of course
when this president has invited just
about
everyone from central america to come on
up into our great united states of
america
these individuals are bringing disease
with them in addition to cove but i mean
we have to make sure that the
individuals that are entering our
southern border
are actually tested but we know we
haven't reached that
point yet and so i just think that it is
a poor excuse
but what what what else was she going to
say she's got to come up with some
excuse
and kova just seems to be the word of
the day every day
and probably for the next several weeks
or months they don't know how to handle
this quite honestly
well you're right it does seem like that
is the messaging going forward
fox news did a poll and looked at border
security today
as opposed to two years ago and as you
can see the biggest number there
uh in it now is that it's worse now than
it was
before and we saw an earlier paul from
another
outfit that said that a majority of
people feel that the reason
our southern border is a magnet is
because of joe biden's policy
that that's pretty clear he made that
clear during the campaign and now
we shouldn't be shocked that this is
happening down there
it is his policy this is a crisis
this is just uh uh listen
the biden administration they actually
enjoy this
which is sad they do not put the
american people first and i said this
several times they said
we must put america first but
they added a word into it they're
putting central america first
she wants to go down and visit you know
guatemala and honduras
she doesn't want to go down to our
southern border and it's we need to
continue to keep up the pressure
we need to continue to have codels go
visit the southern border
and talk about this issue show the
american people
the crisis we have at the southern
border and this is such an
easy fix steve revert back to trump's
policies
yeah come on you're in charge of this
now remember
you're the the point person on this you
need to get up this morning
you need to call president trump and ask
him say sir
how did you have such a secure southern
border and he'll tell her
you need to go back to the remain in
mexico you need to get rid of this catch
and release
and you need to finish the wall that's
how we solve this problem
and it could be done today i got a
feeling uh
she's not gonna make that phone call um
but i do have a question
don't know if you're going to be going
to the president's address before
congress on wednesday night
but what exit question what is the one
thing you would like to hear from joe
biden
i would like to hear joe biden uh let's
play his speech on january 20th
let's go in and play some of his speech
where he talked about bipartisanship and
and work it with my friends on the other
side of the aisle
and then i'd like to ask them the
question how do you think you've done so
far
because there is no bipartisanship we
are a divided country
you said earlier in your poll that 82 of
america
americans feel that we are divided we
certainly are
and as he continues to just placate that
far left freak show of his
uh we're never going to come together as
as a country
all right uh congressman nails we thank
you very much for joining us today from
down in the houston area thank you sir
thank you god bless all right god bless
you